hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to riddled school for the
next one in the series and I'm certain
if I know anything about these games I'm
going to be escaping from some sort of
school for some sort of reason but now
that I know that there's oh a
possibility of some darker themes going
on here I'm curious as to what the hell
is happening here is this going to be a
digital school is this parodying online
schools is this Phoenix University
always so much better oh it's nice I
like this a lot oh excuse me
[Music]
I have a lot of questions here why did
that teacher have a ready access button
that led to a portal to Hell Phil's
teacher mr. munch was the original
architect of riddle University the
school was built above a long pit of
lava that he himself dug near an active
underwater volcano see this is what I
appreciate I ask a question the game
immediately answers it his plan to
murder Phil egg tree to forever rid him
of this world succeeded and the mystery
is solved and there goes the series
thank you everyone so much for joining
us I really do appreciate each and every
one of you let me know what you thought
of this Oh every other student of riddle
University eventually died from car
wrecks old age and unforeseen disasters
each one on their deathbed whispered
their final wish
please don't let there be any more
riddle school games
hmm stay tuned after the credits to see
your time well there you have it once
again I want to say about the impeccable
quality of this game I really did like
the intricate levels and the design of
the school this time because it was
super weird it was like a hypercube
whose four dimensional in a way you got
to go in rooms inside of rooms that led
to other rooms now I don't know how I
figured it all out it must be that I'm a
super genius or something me and John
Breaux we're on the same level over here
when it comes to making these levels and
making these games a super awesome
experience the having a full orchestra
actually play in the middle of the game
was ridiculously cool I love that a lot
it was superb in every aspect of the way
and might I say the graphics like
photorealistic isn't even a word that
could appropriately described the beauty
that I thought I saw it was like peering
into the heavens above it was like
staring into the most beautiful thing in
the world and that literally just blinds
you from its glory I cannot fathom how
he could possibly follow this game up
with another one but we'll get to that
game real soon just as soon as I recover
from this I'm gonna need like a
three-week vacation to emotionally deal
with what just happened in front of this
so either way thank you guys so much for
watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to riddle school
5 now for some reason there is no riddle
school for what no I don't know what no
what are you talking about this is the
start of the video we haven't done
anything before this
I always you need me to do the intro
I'll do the intro again
so welcome to riddle school five riddle
school for was an April Fool's joke
hahaha but now this is a real one so
welcome to riddle school 5 now we all
know how incredible real school 4 was so
it'll be hard to top
well everyone it seems soon our dreams
will become reality BAM just as all of
our prisoners realities have become
dreams we all know our new prisoners
were taken from riddle elementary school
enlighten our listeners as to the reason
we're here already I was getting to that
part of is this meeting is primarily to
discuss these human suspects in their
new dreams their behavior after all is
why and how we're going through with our
plan yes because evildoers do deserve
nothing more than the taste of their own
evil yes this Fred we can read the
caption I'm enlightening everyone just
like you said Fred and his dreams does
as close to nothing as you can imagine
of the prisoners we have he seems to be
the least useful right now smiley smiley
smiles constantly within our dreams
we've tried to find intended flaws in
her ways here not yet to any avail if
one human is to proven to be scum the
rest are no cleaner her face is nothing
but a cover for her ugly desires Zach
here was shivering long before he was
abducted from that school it seems
impossible that he would be so ongoingly
chilly there's a lot chance that by
looking into his unusual condition we
could power a weapon capable of freezing
that pathetic planet Earth I could've
sworn I was the one telling the
presentation and we are here we have the
reason for our master plan had we not
witnessed first hand Phil escaping from
his own school earth would not have
become our first target of destruction
we can get into his brain
but what matters most is what we try to
get out of it knowing the enemy is the
best way to defeat them
it is I can't remember what the plan is
exactly quiz you're completely useless
well I can clarify with the knowledge we
received from these three dream captives
it's planned we completely freeze their
homeworld planet Earth this procedure is
to be repeated to the other wrongdoing
planets I have one more question
go ahead quiz when you're talking just a
second ago you said from the knowledge
we received from these three dream
captives didn't you mean to say four of
course just a slip of the tongue hey why
isn't the transmitter turned off what if
one of our subject hears sorry didn't
even know it was on it'll be turned off
in a sec ah oh it was all a dream it was
all a dream we were never in that school
that's why the school didn't make any
sense
oh hi welcome to the real world
hot-diggity oh [ __ ] we're not gonna be
escaping from a school this time are we
OH
Diddy's oh oh ye meeting in there if it
wasn't screwed to the wall I could get
this cover and move over already then
under the bed odd alien coin okay so
we're still collecting coins here right
light bulb anything anything anything
can't open that remote activate it from
the other side so maybe I can use the
coin
I can't indeed do that and it's so well
animated to a functional coin take these
clues I'll put this fool in the tuna
hello I've decided I don't want to do
that again um okay there's a button on
this duck statue but it doesn't seem to
do anything okay oh it's one of these
puzzles well good thing I'm really good
oh I have to get a certain pattern
that's listed below that's gonna be more
difficult I'm not a hundred percent sure
about my ability to do that
titties oh no oh no oh god damn it I was
close
oh I got one hey I got one of them I
guess if you just flail wildly
eventually you'll get all of them right
maybe probably not it's not how this
works is it there we go got another took
long enough okay
doodlee doodlee doodlee doodlee ah there
we go I got it all force oh oh it was
just numbers I didn't have to do that
for seven oh one look at a done egg time
whoa out of sight out of mind oh nice
semi is that permanent no it's not
hi smiley how you doing well stupid of
you why'd you do that really hope
there's a better way to wake up my
friends yeah that didn't work at all
it's not even away flower ah hello thank
you for you this plants not immediately
dying so I'll take it
yeah it seems like a logical thing to do
or why not take Moo's picture Trey
random picture two-hour commute a weird
Sun barely okay
so ah keycard why would they just leave
a key card in Fred's room here why are
you still doing that you're still dumb
don't do that even though I'm the one
that made you click on that so you can
exactly look at me
that happened uh it's okay for seven hi
got a cute
okay so why isn't it doing anything
about me
willow so escape pods huh all right so
we gotta get our friends first that's
number one
Oh a room that has a bit of acid that's
lovely thank you for that vital
information I'll take that thar when I
forget completely about that and fall
right in okay what about four okay so
what's on the ceiling besides what I its
ectoplasm
there's ectoplasm on the ceiling that's
weird okay huh
life wait life transferring station
living thing goes here dead animal goes
here well that doesn't seem like it's
just a kill o matic it this thing just
murders people to properly transfer life
from a living thing to a dead animal
it's as easy as one two three I also
know that the living thing dies when the
dead a model comes to life oh I thought
it was like a conveyor belt what a
living animal in this side magically
it's dead on the other one
congratulations you've killed it alright
so I have something living here but I
need something dead or at least
something that I want to bring back to
life or maybe um maybe just bring it to
life in general I almost forgot oh wait
yeah yeah this one remember to feed
Oswald the monster he only eats live
meat nitwit oh I almost forgot he
doesn't eat what he can't smell so fine
food with an aroma and put it where
smell can easily spread
huh well there's fruit up here that I
can get so there's got to be something
that I can combine here some kind of key
card that I can use in one oh well
that's handy
hey bike wait but that was my room why
did I need to come right back into my
room what did I need to do that oh I
think I know why because I need to lock
it in there
okay I got it okay so this is gonna hide
me until I need to go that makes a lot
of sense okay another screw okay so oh I
know that's four okay so I need to look
under the beds of all the other subject
that's what I'm doing I see a tissue
obviously used no I'm using that okay
weird this bad see a photo of puking
gorilla under the bed it doesn't quite
tickle my fancy okay so the only thing I
got was a screw Oh power okay so there's
no power oh but I have screws oh that
makes sense okay now that's why I need
four got it oh that's pretty
oh that's real pretty there so why are
the gauges lizards those gauges are
lizards that's that's not just me right
it's it's definitely a thing okay so I
need a 92 dead animal
what am I gonna do oh okay alright okay
okay alright okay ah on the mini-map you
can see there's a tiny itty-bitty gap in
between this room and the next one
ah I don't know why I didn't notice that
before considering I saw the hidden door
I just didn't connect the dots that
there was any possibility that I could
be what that was so I believe I need to
put this in here somewhere make oh no I
need to oh I need to low I got it I
think I have to give this neat life oh I
don't know if this I don't know if is
morally good
ah was it though I think there's a
reason the meat didn't survive with the
plants life
oh well that's convenient I didn't know
about that I don't know what you're
talking about
[Music]
is it oh is it gonna it's gonna all oh
but that doesn't make any sense at all
it's adorable
that that is a reach the only reason I
got that is because I was clicking
absolutely everything to absolutely
everything which is like my last-ditch
resort on puzzle games and I filled the
tray with dirt I mean I get what you're
going for there but
okay all right so now I've got what
amounts to a living steak for some
reason with plant legs but I have to I
imagine I have to place it in here
somewhere but where maybe I gotta oh of
course
so if I hide my yeah go get a buddy move
he's gonna go in there and then I lock
him back in ma'am okay so I got him out
of the way man that was a bit of a
stretch I will readily admit okay hello
uh I shouldn't be in here my brain is
not able to comprehend everything in
here enter the children's dreams in the
jaw I could be wrong but this looks
important and I'm trying to read it
under the children's dreams in the chair
in the next room their dreams will only
end when in them they meet doom
something's clicking in my head I died
oh my friends are physically protected
by barriers because of this I can't
directly wake them up
however ah my dream that went into
college stopped when I was killed their
dreams will only end when in them they
meet doom which means I gotta kill my
friends yeah ooh
killing friends party time oh yeah okay
anyway I probably shouldn't shot that a
dumb four lungs well let's go in here
for seven oh one was that it Boinky
Boinky man this was a key this was a
code for 701 that was good okay but I
gotta go in each of these 72 72 1831
okay 77 tell whoever won we won we won
we will we will I like to think that I
enhance the games that I play with my
clever commentary you know what I mean
so now it all makes sense why was
entering the matrix in here in riddle
school for it was there all along
incredible who would have known who
would have known it oh it's even in the
style
nobody is I think class hasn't started
yet wait a minute Oh Fred never had a
seat in this early so how is this his
dream hey Phil hi is this mr. McMasters
room yes it is indeed it is here's your
seat oh hell yeah yeah okay he's on the
right train of thought okay I didn't get
killed or something all right cool oh
yeah it's that oh yeah oh yeah so now
hey Fred let's see would you like to
wear my sweatshirt
oh yeah cuz in the other one I remember
that it said it was green ah
oh man I remember that oh yeah Oh
um ah so I'm not reading this why I'm
I'm just enjoying myself
you forgot to wake up this morning okay
you have to die you only wore your
underwear see what are your future
career plans I'll stop talking now
goodbye I don't have loads of time so
why would I leave the room well I don't
know description of Phil well I gotta
edit this looks like this is to sit in
that desk man it is connected it is I
need I need I need I need I need oh now
he's gonna want it room is relatively
cold you Fred would you like my
sweatshirt there you go oh it's perfect
it's perfect it's perfect I love it I
love it I love it mr. mines good job mr.
münch fred is now dead
well that shows it all connects it does
connect he's dead okay so 1831 was the
next one 1831
you
I'm not gonna add sound effects of this
one because I don't feel like it's
necessary day enhance the experience you
guys know what's going on right maybe oh
it's a different room oh this is from a
different riddle school Oh is riddles go
three oh [ __ ] we're going back in time
this is so cool oh it's in the style -
ah the familiar mr. Saugus class from my
dream if possible I'm gonna kill smiley
quickly and painlessly but it's probably
not gonna do that probably gonna be flu
and dead hey okay doesn't have a clue
what I'm trying to do so if I remember I
have to get the gum off yeah the gum
stick that here for some reason get a
rubber band and no one notices that this
happens totally fine my god it's the
same so cool and now I'm gonna I'm gonna
smack you with a rubber band until you
die okay do I got to do this - mister
soggy again what being and ship I am
okay so how do I kill you
oh this is so he doesn't see the murder
Oh No
talkies glasses fell on the floor I'm
sure is too bad he can't teach without
him on whoa
smiley frowned oh uh
smiley oh no oh oh no oh no oh no oh
geez oh god I was amazing oh that was
amazing oh I love that
again I gotta check the other six five
five three
oh man that was hilarious oh man I love
that I don't know why I'm saying I love
that just witnessed a murder in this
game but man if there's something I
enjoy whoa boy it was what I just saw
oh man that was hilarious I was gonna be
rid of school one or two how Bad's gonna
be - considering one so long ago oh no
it is is it no it's not that's - its -
its - indeed it is - alrighty then hello
hi
get ready Zach you're about to meet your
maker
I'd like to kill Zach fast so I don't
have to repeat the seventh grade
yeah you could sound more morbid do I
need these quarters is there one in two
quarter-notes nope No
loulou's um Zach oh okay do I need to
know okay I do need to do that
Oh God Oh No Oh No
do I have to just hammer him he's frozen
oh no oh no I guess it's not as bad as
inhaling entire global okay so now I got
them all and apparently I'm gonna be
able to go rescue I'm correct yes hello
you're awake dad because suddenly I felt
cold really cold okay oh I don't know
how we're gonna stop him from destroying
the earth but you know at least is a
good start
hi smiley walking today I woke up from a
really long dream oh yeah and we're also
not on earth anymore but that can be
fixed their escape pods guess I'll see
you on earth Matt you're taking this in
stride at least I guess alright hey
Brett
I know what's going on do you uh yeah
escape pods facility they're gonna
destroy the earth
Oh yadda yadda yadda okay we're done all
right so now it's time for me to go
right I get to join my friends maybe
maybe I have escaped I have escaped I
have escaped okay no I haven't well this
doesn't seem like what I was hoping for
where am I going another alien a more
different alien species well okay Oh
they've got goobie Gabor's oh oh well
this didn't go as planned oh no oh no
they're gonna use his cold power to
freeze the earth marvelous isn't it oh
hi oh very sinister I like you on
that's good touch you keep that up man
you keep that up I am vis decider of
your worlds fate
nice to meet you what's going on here
why don't you ask that cowardly traitor
over there oh hi
oh you're welcome
I'll be taking this thank you okay
goodbye so cowardly traitor what exactly
is going on here I'm a traitor but not
to you my name is diz
is I recognize that name in vis too
weren't you in that meeting in the
transmission before I woke from a dream
you said you were planning to freeze
planet Earth none of this will make
sense unless I start from the very
beginning
it began with vision was a project
started by our leader vis and the one
you too saw he felt it was his duty to
decide the fate of every planet in the
universe he's blinded by playing a
journey begin with your planet Earth
nobody was in agreement to his plan of
course but we are under his rule he gave
his minions one chance to prove earth
wasn't worth erasing we built a local
time stopping mine and set it outside of
an earth school as it would turn out the
riddle of the school was riddle
Elementary School where you were our
hope was that nobody would escape the
school Oh unfortunately that day was the
very same day you left school early time
throughout Earth stopped and vis was
convinced earth had evil intent he
ordered us to abduct you and your
friends before restoring Earth's to keep
there's add a plan to use your evils and
powers against you to destroy earth we
had to look into your minds hence give
you the idea of altered dreams we even
change your clothes a few times to see
if it affected your thoughts so it was
very beginning a traitor coming to the
equation death was the only thing that
could separate you from your dream
alterations to dreams can be easily
detected by just about anyone so I can
only wake you up if I killed you in a
dream after all death is the only thing
that could wake you but any of you all
oh I did not go on seeing however it's
only a matter of time before I found out
oh I want the full mile and altered the
mind of your mr. münch your last dream
teacher i sat behind you and watch the
execution to be sure everything went
well that is why you didn't see me when
you went in the same room with Fred's
dream at that time I was where I am
standing now
the transmitter message you heard was
recording from another time I
transmitted it to you again when I knew
you were about to wake up I did it so
you would know visits plans for your
world and now he's taking Zach's
freezing genes to power up giant laser
not long from now it will have charged
enough to freeze the earth I have only
been trying to help you so you could
save your friends
good job oh [ __ ]
the laser charging if nothing is done
your world will be solid ice not cool
yeah okay my biz so I did the winter
view is reserved for the children
ah okay oh yes psychic powers that's
awfully convenient I'm so sorry I ran
out of cages to trap you and your
friends in you'll still enjoy the show
won't you somehow I really doubt that
I'm sure it will be an unforgettable
spectacle which is why I plan to watch
it on my own ship without distractions
here's both my hands prepare yourself
for the grand finale' tea okay bye sir
so long I guess I'll just be here by
myself thank you for the ship okay
I guess I'm here now well alrighty then
ultra toothpaste vanity area screws I
could use those a [ __ ] mass [ __ ] ok what
goes in probably never comes out well I
just lost those screws but at least this
will come off ok so can I fish him out
with this no he's based oh my god why do
I feel like I'm on a limited time when
I'm definitely not see ok circle pattern
uh committed to memory instantaneously
blue oh I gotta do this again oh god
damn it
got that one oh this one's working
differently than the other one why
didn't I notice that oh my god it is
different
holy [ __ ] ok got that one ok got that
one finally Jesus Christ this is harder
than I thought it would be
here we go finally holy [ __ ] that took
forever oh my god ok what does this mean
[Music]
is it is this really is is that RIT was
that really it oh that's awfully
convenient that the code is written
exactly where that needed to be now I
have a key ah that whoa hello uh-oh I'm
upside down
hang on I'm upside down so maybe that's
supposed to be upside down I know how
you work
I know how you work game BAM oh look at
me I'm amazing I am a mate Oh Lulu why
was that necessary
Oh mug shot oh that's that's hilarious
you're you're hilarious here you're so
funny Oh because let me try going over
here now
something can move it maybe this is a
crowbar Oh
toothpaste ma'am for some reason I don't
know oh man is gonna be a tough one
holy [ __ ] I got it slather that thing
okay so what's that gonna do for me get
some lava maybe combine this on the hook
ah dip it in the lava I'm so smart I am
so smart
lava Java okay alright whatever I'm
gonna ignore that pun for now and then
I'm gonna burn the [ __ ] out of this
there you go that that's how that
physics work okay I got a key for this
how about a Winky how about a little boy
boink
uh-huh okay okay so
now what
it is whatever the hell it is open okay
okay okay okay so now I go the ship
wheel and then I'm done hell yeah freeze
that sucker get him get him get him get
him good good get him good get him real
good
freezin free them good free them
hardcore he likes to be so hot let's see
him cool off for a bit soon this planet
will be covered in a coat of ice yes
any minute now because evil doers
deserve a taste of their own evil ah ha
ha ha ha it was a bit of self punishment
there oh man he said the thing that
that's gonna get him nuts just do this
thing where he's gonna die maybe not die
but to be free
oh that's nice that's real nice there
oh jeez well now he's dead that's a
definite that's it he's on represent
dead death is what happened to him and
he is dead now amazing
you saved earth and disposed of our
wretched leader simultaneously I managed
to escape with this remote I found it
used to be business awesome
maybe I can use this remote to free your
friends oh thanks dude with all that's
happened today that's not a bad
assumption well give it a shot it's
probably not gonna blow him all up oh
he's okay oh she's okay
oh he's probably okay I'm pretty sure I
know how to drive the ship we're in you
all be able to go back to your homes
before you know it I'm not cold anymore
this feels amazing
ah oh [ __ ] I may have learned something
from this experience friends really can
come from anywhere
yeah even space haha all my life I've
been devoted to doing as little as
possible witnessing everything phil has
done helped me realize even a world as
big as ours can be affected by what one
person does I guess I should say I
learned a lot from this experience but
really only one lesson I've learned
truth today's really stands out to me
[Music]
stay in school
oh that's a good life lesson to learn
for everybody stay in school
drink your milk and there you have it
riddle school is over that was quite a
journey and this last one was pretty
dang amazing I gotta say it was a lot
longer than I thought it was gonna be
which is not a bad thing and then again
I got stuck for a while there being
stupid but okay so that's not clickable
but either way this was awesome I had a
lot of fun with this one and to be
perfectly honest there are technically
two more games after this series but I'm
gonna spread them out a bit more I don't
want to just like last through the
entire series as quickly as possible
because it's really good and I really
appreciate the work that went into it
I'm an apparently riddle transfer which
is the next in the series is even bigger
than this and I have no idea I still
have not seen any of the stuff so it's
all completely new to me but either way
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you john breaux who goes by John
Akram now officially which is what I
knew him as
before thank you so much for making this
game and I can't wait to see what more
cool things you make in the future and
what other cool stuff you're gonna be
doing and what you've already done so
thanks again everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna hang around to the
end the credits just to make sure
there's nothing else and then we're
gonna get to the end so just hang on
[Music]
45 minutes oh that's a long time so
either way that is all for this there
are some special features here that you
can check out if you beat the game but
it's really interesting to see how it
all tied together so thank you again
everybody so much for watching and let
me know what you thought in the comments
down below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye hey everything was dusty
that's what I did there
you found my feather duster keep the
change okay thanks I've been looking up
stop throw dodging and basically being a
badass that I am it